[Musik]
urlauber in deutschland stehen an summe
über nacht jetzt wie der staat tausende
gastarbeiter aus der türkei anheuern der
berliner senat schließt verschärfen wer
corona maßnahmen nicht mehr aus und der
verbrenner motor erregt die gemüter und
damit herzlich willkommen zu finden nach
acht meine gäste heute abend sind der
publizist henryk broder erzählt heute
abend bilanz über den g 7 gipfel und
findet das war eine große
steuerverschwendung wie gewohnt kritisch
hat darwin fdp-politikerin anna
elisabeth von treuenfels verein warnt
davor dass ich des corona chaos diesen
herbst wiederholt die anzeichen dafür
dass unsere grundrechte erneut
eingeschränkt werden die sind ja schon
da bild sparzwangs ochse beschäftigt des
urlaubs haus in deutschland ja sagt das
chaos an den deutschen flughäfen ist
eine schande bestsellerautor polizisten
beschäftigt die kennziffer das thema oft
weil es auch sehr wichtig ist und seine
these die politik belohnt die
angepassten die haben verlernt zu
streiten das haben wir werden nach acht
definitiv nicht und dementsprechend
verspricht es eine spannende runde zu
werden mein name ist nina schenk ich
freue mich sehr dass sie eingestellt
haben dass sie lust auf debatte haben
dass sie lust auf streit haben meine
thierse heute abend ist der verbrenner
darf nicht sterben denn michaels heute
etwas geärgert der kompromiss der eu zum
verbrenner aus wird gerade gefeiert aber
er geht überhaupt nicht weit genug was
ist eigentlich passiert jetzt wird erst
mal ein bisschen trocken bleiben für
bereiten die umweltminister der 27 eu
staaten hatten sich darauf geeinigt dass
ab 2035 nur noch klimaneutrale neuwagen
verkauft werden sollen zusätzlich hat
dann die fdp diego fühlt sich aber die
fdp feiert als kompromiss einen
vorschlag gemacht wie nach 2035
fahrzeuge zugelassen werden können die
ausschließlich mit klimaneutralen
kraftstoffe näfels betrieben werden als
pro marktwirtschaft lerin geht mir aber
dieser kompromiss überhaupt nicht weit
genug ich sehe generell das verbot einer
technologie als kritisch an der
verbrenner ist der kern unserer
industrie die deutsche industrie hat
viel viel mehr wettbewerbsvorteile beim
verbrenner als beim batterie elektroauto
alle die in deutschland das verbrenner
aus also herbei sehen wie
bundesumweltministerin steffi lemke
mal wieder hoch motiviert an dem ast auf
dem wir alle sitzen bei alle anderen
eu-länder haben kleine oder keine
autoindustrie also ich wenn ich das mag
vereinfacht formulieren darf würde
spanien seine strände sperren um natur
und meerestiere zu schützen natürlich
nicht spanien braucht den tourismus
apropos umwelt das batteriebetriebene
elektroauto ist jetzt auch nicht die
ganz glorreiche umwelt lösung aktuelle
batterien brauchen nämlich die rohstoffe
aus china kongo russland wir wissen ja
alle wie schwierig diese geopolitische
abhängigkeit für uns ist stichwort
atomkraft
dementsprechend bin ich fest davon
überzeugt dass die politik einfach den
markt entscheiden lassen soll wenn ein
kunde mit seinen ganz persönlichen
lebensumständen sich dafür entscheidet
dass ein batterie elektro auto besser
ist wird er dieses auf kaufen ohne zwang
uns zum richtigen preis aber die politik
sein endlich auf wenn unternehmer zu
spielen
und wir sind ja letztlich stolz darauf
dass wir auch eine autonation sind da
sind wir da nicht mehr also elektroautos
für mich eine sache der upper class wäre
es schlau wer holt sich das ein paar
gelder aus den fördertöpfen und dass
wenn ich menschen in e autos zählt das
sind alles gut angezogene leute ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass der arbeiter
sich ein e auto leisten kann oder jemand
der auf dem land lebt wie soll man sich
das vorstellen da steht man dann wenn
ich dann zum arzt in dieser stadt muss
erstmal die steckdose oder so ich kann
mir das nicht vorstellen wir müssen
autonation bleiben also für dich ist das
e auto deen typische grüne klientel
politik absolut ich gebe dem autor auch
eine chance aber tatsächlich muss es
wirklich so sein dass ich mir dass am
ende auch leisten kann und dass ich dann
fahren kann wenn ich auch fahren will
und nicht noch an die steckdose muss
herr bode erfahren sie denn ein
elektroauto ein verbrenner ich könnte
nie so tief sinken wie ein elektroauto
zu kaufen das geht gar nicht außerdem
bin ich schon muss in eine völlig
zustimmen ich finde auch einfach
unanständig dass der arbeit sind erwähnt
haben denn eine mittel- oder
oberklässler das elektroauto mit
finanziert weil er die steuern zeit von
sind die auto prämien bezahlt verzichtet
also jemanden sehen denn umwelt schon
luxus eines elektroautos kauft wird von
uns allen von den dummen hier noch mit
9000 euro pro stück glaub mich
unterstützt und es ist
wir können in unseren verbrenner reihen
wir machen das verbrenner auto an und
fahren einfach los ja so als wäre die
batterien jetzt beim elektrode völlig
umwelt schonen und als wäre das die
herstellung nötig umwelt schonen die
entsorgung ist es nicht aber trotzdem
teilige ihre aufregung nicht weil daraus
wird nichts wir können in so einer liste
von sachen auf schon die eu beschlossen
die nicht durchgekommen sind zum
beispiel keine vergesellschaftung der
schulden nicht wahr und andere
kleinigkeiten
wir haben mit 20 22 35 soll der elektro
motor nicht mehr hergestellt und
ausgeliefert werden da sind 12 13 jahre
nicht wahr in 2 13 jahren kann viel
passieren und ich finde ein zeichen von
optimismus
unverantwortlichkeit prognosen über
zwölf jahre hinweg zu machen und dieses
jahr haben wir entdeckt dass die
bundesbahn marode ist das deutsche
straßennetz runderneuert werden aus
lauter überraschungen und hier machen
die pläne zwölf jahre im voraus wissen
sie in zwölf jahren werden wir eine
chinesische provinz sein wenn wir glück
haben wir kein glück haben sind ja nicht
so dass ein arabisches oder ich mag sie
wirklich sehr aber das finde ich dass so
wenig macht extrem wir waren einfach
nicht kann man so schnell nicht
vorstellen was kostet dann so liter öko
benzin ist er dann billiger oder teurer
doch nicht das ist doch kein zufall dass
wir das auch nicht erfahren ich mal wir
sind nur überall glückliche leute ich
finde einen campari die anderen laufen
klöco viel alkohol kann es nicht geben
weil die herstellung energie intensiven
weil sie ganz viele voraussetzungen das
weiß man noch nicht wie es bis halt dann
2035 ist mit e fuß oder auch wasserstoff
als ob es dann möglich ist dass die
klimaneutral sind auch die verbrenner
durchlaufen die auch mit kölnisch wasser
und wir wissen schon angst aber ich
wollte jetzt braucht treuenfels frowein
christian linder unser finanzminister
und fdp boss hat ja heute getwittert
nein zum verbrenner aus dann hab ich mir
das alles mal ganz genau angeschaut und
so ganz groß ist das nein von der eu ja
nicht es ist ja nur ein kompromiss
gefunden wie eine hintertür wie sehen
sie das denn na ja an die fdp heute
feiern zum feiern finde ich gut dass
deswegen kein grund möglich ja kein
geheimnis dass wir immer gesagt haben
wir sagen auf keinen fall macht wieder
mit aber es ist ein kompromiss gefunden
worden und zumindestens haben wir
rausgeholt dass jetzt die kommission an
vorschlag erarbeiten soll und da gebe
ich ihnen recht mal sehen was da so
kommt das ver brenner weiter zugelassen
werden wenn sie mittels getankt werden
ist ja schon mal mehr als wenn man
gleich da diesem mainstream beugt ich
selber sehe das ist links ich sehe ich
sehe es ein bisschen so wie sie ich
glaube man muss das ein bisschen
entspannter sehen ich glaube auch
ehrlich sagt dass die autoindustrie ein
bisschen mehr schafft als wie heute
denke ich glaube nicht dass wir daran
jetzt zu grunde gehen als 1 und meine
zweite these ist ich finde mehr so die
infrastruktur die ladeinfrastruktur das
ist doch das problem wenn viele autos
auf den markt kommen werden sie nicht
mehr subventioniert dann kann sich die
glaube ich auch jeder leisten da muss
man jetzt nicht zwischen arm und reich
trennen das würde ich glaube ich nicht
so sehen aber die infrastruktur
herzustellen einer stadt zum beispiel
mit einer wohnung ist doch jetzt schon
so in hamburg das stimmt die grünen
fahren eine solche autos ich weiß nicht
wo tappen die diese autos eigentlich
dass das glaube ich eher das problem und
ich würde sagen dass man muss das
bisschen runter wochen wir haben gesagt
das wird schon funktionieren das wird
uns nicht kaputt machen
wir haben also sind sie nicht mitmachen
ach jetzt wenn ich wirklich mal auf die
atomkraft zurück schaue da hat man ja
auch gesagt das wird alles mit den
erneuerbaren energien würde klappt jetzt
sind wir unfassbar abhängig und die
meisten viele bereuen sind jetzt begeben
wir uns also wieder in die geopolitische
abhängigkeit obwohl wir beim verbrenner
wirklich in deutschland die absoluten
also das ist unsere dna das können wir
waren schon wieder zu was was wir können
sagen nein wobei von seiten der politik
anstatt nicht die autoindustrie lösungen
finden zu lassen mit
technologieoffenheit und auch mit
vorgaben das ist immer weiter runter was
ist ja genau was ich auch denke aber nun
da stimme ich ihm ja wirklich so dass
ich auch kein geheimnis dass wir so
denken aber es ist nun mal so dass es
auch keine haben dass es ein kompromiss
gefunden werden muss und wir haben uns
in vielen dingen bis jetzt als fdp gut
durchgesetzt unter rot-grün wäre noch
ein bisschen schlimmer geworden so es
ist ein kompromiss ist ein kapitel ein
kompromiss ist kein wert an sich nein
das habe ich nicht gesagt noch nicht
fertig als wäre der kompromiss nicht
erstattet und folgen es gibt zwischen
ich sagen er wird das finde ich kann
jetzt nicht vergleichen vielen dank für
den anruf ja findet trotzdem und dabei
bleibe ich man muss das bisschen
entspannter sehen ich glaube nicht dass
die autoindustrie daran kaputt geht weil
mich wundert immer dass viele autos
drücken das steht mir auch sagen also
mit denen ich spreche doch wir finden
das gut ich wundere mich darüber ich
finde mal so ich dachte früher immer so
wir als fdp sagen soll
technologieoffenheit und bloß kann er
autos und viele vertreter lang nur das
studentische automobilzulieferer denken
immer nur an die großen konzerne das
rückgrat der deutschen wirtschaft sind
die familienunternehmen jahren
eigentlich die mittelständler absolute
top im sauerland oder woanders und da
muss man auch ganz klar sagen viele
automobilzulieferern finde es nicht gut
wenn sie sagen jetzt nicht das ist das
glück zahlt sich auf jeden fall klar ja
und ich finds ja auch nicht richtig gut
also meine ich sage was ich denke ja es
ist ja nicht so dass ich sagen würde ich
finde ich jetzt richtig prima und das
müssen wir für das klima tun so denke
ich ja nicht ich finde auch das muss der
markt entscheiden ist das ja auch immer
unsere auffassung gewesen es ist aber
nun so wie es ist und ich will mich doch
nicht verarschen denken wir haben alles
zugestimmt aber ich denke trotzdem dass
christina schon sehr deutlich gemacht
und da wird auch sicher hinterher sein
dass dieser vorschlag hat sich in schall
und rauch verschwindet sondern das was
dann auch passiert
erzählte steht denn die politik für
kompromisse vielleicht auch für faule
kompromisse wofür steht für die politik
ich finde sie hat im moment etwas sehr
ideologisch ist also wir haben ja schon
energiewende und die erneuerbaren die
können das alles diese technologie
geschlossenheit sagen wir mal beim thema
motorantrieb dass man ganze sachen
ausblendet also meines wissens ist
toyota hält die wasserstoff den
wasserstoffantrieb für
vielversprechendsten investiert da rein
also man schießt sich irgendwie bisschen
vermessen
planwirtschaftlich schießt sich auf
irgendwelche ziele 1 und bleibt dann bei
der einen technologie jetzt bei der
energiewende glaube ich auch dass das
gar nicht funktionieren kann das ist das
einfach physisch nicht möglich ist weil
da halt winter flauten haben weil wir
zeiten haben wo die sonne gar nicht
scheint also man fühlt sich ein bisschen
mao tsetung habe ich neulich eine
sendung darüber gesehen über seinen
großen sprung nach vorne wo die die
bauern dann irgendwelche hochöfen in
ihren hinterhöfen bauen mussten und ihre
pfannen und das ist ein gewagter
vergleich also völlig wertlosen stahl
eigentlich produziert haben und dafür
sagt schon in deutschland erinnert wenn
sie das sehen ja
dieses sich einschießen und dieses
dieser patriotismus ist vielleicht nicht
aber die energiewende hat schon so ein
bisschen was und alle anderen sind
natürlich geisterfahrern die engländer
die finden die ihre atomkraftwerke
behalten oder auch noch ausbauen das
sind die wir sind die vorreiter und die
sind alles sind alles geisterfahrer ich
würde da können wir denn auch die frage
würde ich gerne an sie richten am ende
denn dann auch ohne autoindustrie leben
wenn jetzt sagen wir die konzerne
schaffen es nicht die elektroautos da
sind wir jetzt noch nicht die
marktführer weltweit wie wir das dann
aussehen naja das natürlich nicht also
ich meine ich kann jetzt auch nicht das
ist kaffeesatzleserei
es können sich wirklich nicht sagen aber
ich denke auf keinen fall können wir das
natürlich gehört das zu uns ja aber
dennoch glaube ich man muss ja irgendwie
erstmal glaube ich ist der weg viel
länger als wir denken da stimme ich
ihnen ganz das könnte man bisschen
entspannter sehen was die sich da so
ausdenken ist eben dauert ein bisschen
bis es umgesetzt wird aber ich glaube
schon dass die autoindustrie umstellen
kann das ist ja was auch so deutschlands
wirtschaft ausmacht dass die schnell
eine lösung finden dass das jetzt auf
dieses elektroauto so kapriziert das
finde ich auch falsch weil wir sagen
immer technologieoffenheit da muss auch
diese offenheit sein und nicht irgendwie
wir geben vor und die sollen mir schon
ein bisschen hinterher produzieren also
sehen das ganze ist noch dass kaisers
neue kleider die leute wissen dass es
nicht gehen wird die eu hat mehrere
jahre gebraucht um eine verordnung für
die herstellung von schnullern
herauszugeben
solche gibt es 100 die können es einfach
nicht schaffen aber wir müssen diesen
therapeutischen zirkus veranstalten
damit der eindruck entsteht die machen
was er sind viele technologien hier
abgeschafft worden deutschland wird nie
wieder irgendwann atomkraftwerk bauen
das dominiert die russen und die
chinesen und die franzosen ein anderer
unter entwickeln nationen die nicht
unserer hohen moralischen standards
haben hier ist die genforschung
praktisch abgeschafft worden es gibt
keine stammzellen forschung in
deutschland hat sich auch sehr viel im
verabschiedet und irgendwie geht es
immer weiter aber war atomkraftwerke
also dass das würde ich jetzt gar nicht
unbedingt sagen wir zumindestens finden
also ich finde das jedenfalls dass wir
auch dass sich ausschließen können dass
wir können jetzt nicht irgendwie in
schmutziger kohle investieren und sagen
das finden wir jetzt wieder prima wohl
noch vorher alles das immer mit wollen
wir das atomkraftwerk philippsburg in
sich zusammengefallen wie auch immer ich
will nur sagen da würde ich sagen also
das ist auch in der politik ich weiß ja
aus bei den grünen angekommen ist die
haben sich ja lange da so bisschen
rausgehen brennstäben rauf und runter
und alle dachten okay das geht alles gar
nicht jetzt hat sich herausgestellt dass
ist doch geht ja und dann muss man das
auch machen
wir sind eine situation haben sie ja
gerade richtig gesagt wir waren richtig
abhängig davon russland werde daraus
sollen und die preise nicht total
hochgehen lassen wollen dann muss man
das machen ganz einfach mich hat ja eh
und die eu beschäftigt ihr bruder hat ja
g7 beschäftigten super übergangs
irgendwann fantastisch gehörgang sehr
gut sie haben eine volle zustimmung wir
haben diesen elmau zirkus kabel zum
zweiten mal bereits und ich saß da von
dem fernsehen schaut der hin- und dachte
das ist ja wie früher im kommunismus die
leute treffen sich sind alle einer
meinung und wie üblich weiß auch in
veranstaltungen wird das schluss
kommunität schon am anfang verfasst und
zwar nicht von den teilnehmern sondern
von der sogenannten sherpas in den
leuten zu arbeiten und das ganze ist
eine darstellung des umgetan lotto bafin
will der schecks gesagt dieses spektakel
866 millionen euro gekostet was eine
unglaubliche summe ist aber für andere
ist das peanuts wenn wir den chinesen
450 millionen euro entwicklungshilfe
schicken dann sind 160 millionen euro
wirklich nicht so viel das waren 18.000
polizisten unterwegs die leute in der
gegend habe sich beklagt weil das ganze
leben zum stillstand kam und ich habe es
so empfunden mit meiner hysterischen
überempfindlichkeit wie eine
generalprobe für den polizei statt es
wurde alles still gelegt dass private
sicherheit über alles andere und dann
bin ich doch ein bisschen getröstet
worden weil ich ein zitat von olaf
scholz daher seit medium auf allen
seinen wegen ein zitat von olaf scholz
gefunden habe er hat betont dass er die
zeit mit seiner ehefrau britta ernst
beim gipfel genossen habe sie merken
worauf ich hinauswill beim g7-gipfel ja
für uns war das natürlich schön dass wir
zusammen sein konnten sagte scholz denn
wir haben beide sehr enge terminkalender
wenn man das was man politisch zu tun
hat verbinden kann damit dass man
zusammen ist dann ist das etwas ganz
besonderes sagte olaf scholz jetzt
wissen sie wo zu elmar gut war das war
eine paartherapie für die schweiz
eigentlich waren die geissens dafür
vorgesehen aber die waren schon
ausgebucht also mussten gefolgt war das
finde ich und sehen kann denn das
damenprogramm herr bruder dieses nordic
walking die daran wärmen
ich war nicht eingeladen ja das weiß ich
ja
ok expedia bruder ich wollte da hab ich
ja wenigstens alles soziale kontakte
ja es gab ein damenprogramm deine frau
makro und die frau von herrn scholz
diesen zusammen nordic walking gegangen
darüber haben sich viele beschwert dass
dass wir die rolle der frau ist beim
g7-gipfel die dem entsprechen die frage
an sie wie kann sie denn das
damenprogramm also das hat mich
überhaupt interessiert ehrlich gesagt so
dass das kenne ich ja auch bei g20 schon
also das ist für mich ob vorstelle ich
gesagt ja wenn ich auch ich sagt
überflüssig finde ich schön wie die sich
treffen aber wenn dann so gezeigt wird
also aber ich sehe es nicht ganz so wie
sie weil ich finde schon dass die auch
miteinander reden müssen
hundertprozentig auch dass es zu teuer
das muss auch nicht in ellmau
stattfinden was schon finde ich auch so
für die deutsche bevölkerung die jetzt
wirklich unter chor ohne wirklichen
guten hat sehr enger schnallen müssen da
muss noch mehr tun hat da schon ein
symbol würde ich auch sagen wie du komm
runter schalten
aber dass sie sich treffen miteinander
reden finde ich das finde ich wirklich
wichtig weil in videokonferenzen kann
man das so nicht besprechen und wir
haben ja im fernsehen alle mitverfolgt
dieser so geschlendert sind und sich
unterhalten haben so ich glaube schon
dass da auch gesagt ja partout
nicht jetzt nicht denn damals wirklich
alles ist schon wichtig dass die
miteinander reden und ich finde das auch
als botschaft an russland nicht so ganz
unwichtig dass das der putin sieht da
kommt ja nicht dazwischen und das finde
ich jetzt von daher gesehen auch in
dieser schweizer und schloss nur eine
flotte nicht aber was er wollte ist uns
auseinander bringen wenn er mal wieder
sieht dass das nicht schafft ist das gut
dass da jetzt nicht sowas 1000 prozentig
neues rausgekommen ist okay nichts kann
man nicht sagen ich finde schon im blick
auf die ukraine haben sie sich schon
einmal wieder meer geeinigt und ich
glaube das ist für herrn scholz auch
nicht ganz unwichtig dass er sieht also
hier der beiden delta will das auch
wirklich und die müssen sich dann hab
ich auch gegenseitig bestärken ich finde
so ein g 7 ist schon das richtige also
ich muss sagen in welchen der fdp weit
zu bringen dass überhaupt nicht das
haben der schaden aber ist
ihren worden rochelle mal ein kompromiss
sein zwischen bahnhofsmission und im
gran hotel irgendwo dazwischen helm auf
warum findet das nicht auf einem kreuz
schiff statt irgendwo in der sänger
warum ich auf einer insel borkum und
helgoland würden sich wahnsinnig freuen
geht's jetzt sozusagen uns geld wie
meyer waren es nur ums geld ich bezahle
ist ja ich weiß nicht wie sie ihre
steuern vermeiden ich trage meine
und dann ich bitte sie was haben sie
gemacht haben der ukraine versprochen
sie als kandidaten aufzunehmen das war
vorher schon klar und im übrigen glaube
ich nicht dass sie sich treffen müssen
die treffen sich alle naslang die können
das ganze unter summe erledigen dass das
war ja ich habe das auch nicht es ist
doch wirklich so ich finde es auch mal
okay wenn die sich auch mal menschlich
kennenlernen ich finde das damenprogramm
auch ganz okay aber gut der gebäude über
all das ist natürlich schon verstören
und 18.000 polizisten mussten auch nicht
sein aber ich bin auch der meinung die
sieben muss einfach sein bin ich total
ihrer meinung einfach mal ein bisschen
auch wenn die bauchbinde von johnson
sind aber irgendwie paar muskeln was man
schon mal da hab ich bitte sie das ist
doch nicht der grund der politik dass
leute zusammenkommen dann kann man den
gleichen kegelbahn mieten sie da ein
lager das aber eine symbolik finde ich
und mir gut getan und ja ich habe mich
nicht gefreut sehen sie
da kann man sparen kann man das ist
schon nochmal ein bisschen es so hans
joas steuergeld es ist sozusagen ein
schaulaufen der versage gewesen zwei
jogger mit seinen treffern nicht zurecht
man kann man eben eine wahl vergeigt
scholz hat total versagt vor fünf jahren
beim g 20 gipfel hatte ich habe trotzdem
gewählt also
nein sonst und ist vollkommen ratlos
seine eigene partei gegen diese leute
die es nie schaffen ihr eigenes geschäft
zu finden weil europa führen und
übernehmen mein bruder ist versager
nicht ein hartes wort für alle direkt
nach wissen sie noch was andere sagen
das würde bedeuten dass sie finden dass
die regierung geschäft jetzt keine
außenpolitik mehr zusammen machen
sollten weil sie in ihrem land ein
problem haben das ist eine schnelle
thema
ist wissen sie und wenn ich nicht
imstande bin mein zimmer aufzuräumen
die sie nicht auffordern in ihrem haus
ordnung zu schaffen aber wenn es dabei
probleme nicht gerade so groß dass man
als gesehen zusammenrücken muss und
vielleicht auch einfach mal sagen muss
so wir müssen nicht mehr viel zusammen
rücken das nächste mal komme ich mit
aller von britta mit und wir können
zusammen
nein schauen sie die leute müssen
beweisen dass sie es können der einzige
der irgendwie einen guten eindruck
gemacht hat fand war tragen tragen
dieser distanziert hat er das gesagt hat
es auf den punkt gebracht und dann war
noch eine der kaiser von japan wie heißt
der kamikaze oder so ähnlich ja ja der
taufe nichts gesagt dass der arme japan
und was haften also eigentlich vererzung
g7 kommen und nicht sagen ganz
bitter sich da sitzen die leute um den
runden tisch schon die fotografen
fotografieren einzigartiger ereignisse
und dann geht die tür zu meiner
umgekehrt müsste sein wenn es relevant
ist und wenn die was wichtige
besprechung livestream liveticker
als sie das hätten sie auch gern
leistung von g7 gehabt für uns bürger
ich weiß ich verteidige so ein bisschen
auch immer das recht auf privatheit also
ist darf besprechungen geben die in
zimmern stattfinden unter sich wo man
mal informell wo man mal sagt was man
nicht sagt wenn die kamera gerade läuft
müssen uns nicht in irgendwelche
verschwörungstheorien oder bösen
bilderberger und da wird ganz schlimmes
besprochen ich find's ok dass das
vertraute rahmen gibt ich bin auch
bereit dafür zu zahlen wenn es grenzen
des anstands einhält ja das müssen jetzt
nicht irgendwelche mit blattgold
vergoldeten stakes wie bei herrn ribery
in dubai sein aber müssen auch nicht
vergessen es gibt ja manchmal auch
spannungen zwischen sogenannten
liberalen demokratien also herr broder
ist ja experte für island da gab es ja
mit großbritannien auch die sogenannten
kabeljau kriege ja unfallstelle eine
echte wo die sich zum teil über den bug
geschossener jetzt ganz gut wenn die mal
zusammen besoffen im wald spazieren
gegangen sind oder nordic walking oder
da ihr sie haben gar nicht das konzert
vom blick für die lösung der konflikte
zwischen nord und südkorea gemeinsam
spazieren gehen sich dann die kante
geben es ist es ist auf bestimmte regime
wahrscheinlich nicht
gute miteinander klarzukommen als
zusammen am tresen gestanden haben muss
in ein getrunken haben ich finde ich
schon ewig in erinnerung und generell
haben wir ja so ein ganz komisches
puritanische zeitalter wo jetzt schon
über den urinalen steht kenn dein limit
oder und welche kampagnen ich finde das
gut also ein dass da jetzt können wir
damit geben wir haben eine politisch
aufrufen zu mehr alkohol können also
alles kein problem ab heute defekten als
psychologe sei es gibt ja so orte wo
bestimmte soziale regeln aufgehoben sind
und das ist ja und ein optischer zoom
das rockkonzert oder das fußballstadion
ist und dass es ok wenn auch eliten orte
haben wo sie mal bisschen anders
miteinander
g7 war gut ihn bestimmten grenzen des
anstands das muss wie gesagt nicht das
verbindet ist so ein grenzen des
anstands für sie jetzt in der
beobachtung letztlich genau die
abrechnung angeguckt was da alles getan
wurde mit nordic walking oder was da der
spesen ist aber ich denke dass hält sich
schon in westlichen staat in den grenzen
und das ist auch unsere drei oder vier
armen afrikaner eingeflogen und die
dürften dann onkeltom spielen für dieser
runde alter weißer männer das ist uns
egal das ist das ist populismus gut das
ist die stärke der aus afrika kamen
mussten auch noch so tun als wären sie
dankbar weil sie mussten ja nicht
konnten also ich meine dass ich jetzt
echt ist gab einen freiflug ja und aber
ich mache ja mit hayward wo das zimmer
1000 euro die nacht
natürlich würde nicht wohin kommt wenn
ich nicht umhin kommen will wegen als
hotelzimmer ist ganz ehrlich wenn ich
dann wäre nach new york werde dann gehe
ich doch nicht hin genau und vor allen
dingen würden wenn sie sowas sagen dass
man sie so behandeln auch gleichzeitig
unterstellen dass die sich so behandeln
lassen so als ob sie irgendwie weniger
werden also ist es doch nicht sondern
sie sind dahin gekommen wie warschau
liegt bei ihm
fand ich jetzt nicht weil ich es muss
nach modell stünde das will ich jetzt
noch gewartet als alles andere sicher
silber aber das nehme ich jetzt mal
einfach so mit ich finde schon die da
einzuladen mit denen zu sprechen
ein ganz gutes zeichen das müsste man
sowieso viel mehr öffnen als es jetzt
geöffnet ist das ist eigentlich die
frage finde ich reichte die sieben
wirklich reichen länder zusammen sitzen
und ich finde auch ein bisschen zu teuer
in der immer geld ausgegeben haben aber
sich unterhalten was ich wiederum gut
finde oder muss man sich noch öffnen und
die am 1 über die gesprochen haben war
neu nichts was die bestimmen wie viel
gesprochen wissen wir jetzt zum glück
das ist das problem das ich gut dass ich
doch gut lassen sich doch mal
untereinander ja natürlich finde ich das
gut finden es gut wenn die politiker
zusammen sitzen und silbernen löffel
bald bier herr bruder fährt so ist ja so
nicht ronzheimer hinschicken dann gibt
es wieder den handy alarm bei bild das
könnt ihr wirklich einen wendehammer vor
ort ist wer bestimmt was auf viele
sorgen aktentasche tragen so schlecht
ich mich rein ja sehr unauffällig
bestimmte herrlich aber während der
jetzt hier ein sehr heiterer stimmung
zusammen sitzen gibt es in diesem land
ja wirklich sehr ernste probleme und das
ist das urlaubs chaos was gerade ganz
viele menschen betrifft und damit weiter
zur frage ob sie
also ich kann nicht wirklich richtig
aufregen denn wenn ich im urlaub war
dann muss sich dreimal anstehen ich muss
an stehend beim check-in ich muss an
steht eine sicherheit am ende noch am
kofferband ich hab selbst mitgemacht da
pulsiert wirklich der da geht mein
blutdruck hoch wirklich ich habe angst
dass ich mein flieger vielleicht
verpasse aber das ist doch wirklich kein
urlaub und er ist als letzte möglichkeit
erholen wir jetzt 4000 der gastarbeiter
aus der türkei hierher hier gibt es doch
genug menschen die hier auch arbeiten
wollen wenn die löhne halt stimmen ich
habe mir angeschaut so ein
sicherheitsbedienstete an der
fluggastkontrolle der verdient 2400 euro
brutto das ist doch gar nix ich kann das
auch verstehen dass wir dann abgewandert
sind die logistik der dhl boote krieg so
minimum
3200 also ich finde faire löhne müssen
da einfach sagen dieses flugchaos ist
wirklich eine schande für deutschland
wenn ich da stehe ich fühle mich da
körper verletzt also mich regt das total
auf wir kommen einfach nach corona nicht
wieder richtig in den tritt und das muss
wirklich ein ende haben
bravo
herstellung der bruder sie haben
vollkommen recht nur mich überrascht mal
leder dass sie überrascht sind wenn
wissen sie ich nehme an mit dem ende von
corona hat niemand gerechnet so wie
putin nicht damit gerechnet dass die
ukraine die leute ganz zu hause und
machen sich ein genaueres können und
jetzt glaubt niemand wusste auch mal in
diesem langen lebens hat ein feld das
die urlaubssaison anwenden dass wir ein
system sei anfällig ich war 23 mal am
berliner flughafen versuche das nie
wieder zu tun dass steht übrigens auf
meinem blog ist ganz oben
ich bin neulich ich bin neulich in
regionalzügen bis nach warschau gefahren
das war angenehm als da schlange zu
stehen aber es waren alle überrascht
verstehen sie das ist das land der
absoluten kompetenz wenn die nicht mal
wissen dass im sommer leute verreisen
und weine wir haben doch ein
verkehrsminister und die ministerin ich
weiß dass ich kein west wir haben herr
wissing von der fdp wissen und sagt das
herz ist dass ich
einige schon nicht mehr es ist den haben
sie gefeuert nein es ist ja eine neue
regierung und der neue ego
der horror amtes gemacht ein paar
monaten habe es nicht gemacht ich war
für uns aber das ist eigentlich fast ein
bisschen schlimm weil sie können jetzt
nicht dafür verantwortlich machen sonst
ging es dann eher scheuer sie meinen der
show wurde begnadigt bevor ich zum
verfahren kommen ja nein das würde ich
nicht sagen dass noch nicht alle halbe
milliarde euro vergeudet mit seinem
wunderbaren maut flammen damit kommt man
hier davon ich würde sagen dass herr
steuer auf einen plan a also der nicht
aufgegangen ist aber ich möchte noch
einmal zu dem urlaubs chaos zurückkommen
frank du hast ja gesagt dass wir hier
genügend leute haben in deutschland die
arbeiten wollen wie kommst du darauf ich
muss ich muss sagen ich habe das gelesen
und dachte mir erst mal die idee ist
doch gar nicht so schlecht der politik
zu sagen wir holen arbeiter per wir
wollen arbeiten nach deutschland dies
machen möchten wir haben ja auch gerade
nicht eine eine exorbitant hohe
arbeitslosenquote in deutschland also wo
kein problem mit den gastarbeitern finde
ich habe eine frau habe gar nichts gegen
die gastarbeiter
lena ich finde nur halt wenn du für 2400
euro dichter beflügeln lassen muss ich
will auch sauer ehrlicherweise bin ich
auch immer schlecht gelaunt wenn ich
alleine sicherheitskontrolle stehe
und das wirst du dir halt am ende auch
nicht geben wahrscheinlich und dann wie
wir es auch gehört haben die mitarbeiter
sind dann abgewandert andere branchen
und jetzt stehen die alle da und wir
wussten dass gar nicht wie gesagt nicht
überhaupt gibt es doch gar nicht kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen das geld wieder
weisen ja genau das ist doch schleppern
und jeder anbieter die politik sowie sei
die politik das machen sollte jetzt
komplett in löhne eingreifen einen
flughäfen oder wie wäre das szenario
dass mögliche gewinne ausweisen
bundesarbeitsminister wirklich
tarifstrukturen zu schaffen dass er dass
dieser job wieder attraktiv wird also
dass das erasmus das reicht schon sie
haben das damit kann man doch mal
anfangen sie haben dasselbe problem in
der gastronomie sie haben große
gaststätte nummer 23 kellner sich die
seele aus dem leib laufen weil die leute
die gekündigt wurde und kurzarbeit
geschickt wurden nicht wiedergekommen
sind ja das tue ich weg sie haben das in
restaurants hotels überall im ganzen
dienstleistungsgewerbe aber da hast du
am ende noch ein bisschen trinkgeld also
am ende wird
wir brauchten wir brauchen fachkräfte
haben wir nicht vor sechs oder sieben
jahren sondern eine große zuwanderung
von facharbeitern gehabt die uns
versprochen wurde was ist denn daraus
geworden ich habe da auch nichts
mitbekommen oder müssen die ganzen
facharbeiter aus 20.15 geblieben da muss
man jetzt natürlich sagen das muss man
sich alles immer ganz genau anschauen
und vorreiterin ziehen absolut muss man
differenziert auch die andere seite
hören auch das
konzept gut verstanden ja absolut
absolute wo ich ja nur ihretwegen
gekommen
aber aber frank du willst ja auch
eigentlich eher dass auch deutsche wenn
ich sie richtig verstehe diese jobs
übernehmen dass sie wieder attraktiv
werden und du bist für tarifstrukturen
absolut und wenn wir die tarife erhöhen
und keiner will an der
sicherheitskontrolle am check in
arbeiten dann ist das alles in gute idee
wirklich aus dem ausland und sich
fachkräfte daran sollen aber das müsste
man auch erstmal ausloten
wenn jetzt die fachkräfte in welcher
sprache wollen sie mit ihnen reden
kriege ich ein problem wenn ich die auf
armenisch nedas werden menschen sein die
gut deutsch können dass sich auch eine
voraussetzung das wird man ja auch nicht
da machen ausbilden und herrschaften ja
ja die sollen angeblich schon so eine
sicherheits überprüfungen haben also die
könnten wohl wenn ich das glaube was mir
heute erzählt worden ist die sind quasi
schon recht ich mal ein satz wie ihn
warten aber auch noch besser wird jetzt
war es und zwar sofort ja bevor wir in
tarifautonomie eingreifen ich glaube das
ist eine schwierige geschichte die
könnte passieren dass es überhaupt zu
diesen gehört dass wir waren ehrlich das
verstehe ich und ich hab dann haben euch
mal abgefragt werden haben wir finden
das eine und dann habe ich mal eine
kleine anfrage gestellt an senat platte
wie sieht's aus das problem sofort nach
berlin geschoben wir haben ja gar nichts
damit zu tun obwohl hamburg ja auch am
flughafen beteiligt ist und natürlich
sind die auch mitverantwortlich die
können sich da genauso darum kümmert und
ich sehe das ein bisschen so wie sie die
sagen sich okay hier ist ein problem ist
jetzt dass meine zeit lang aus wird sie
schon erledigen natürlich erledigt sich
das nicht aber erst dann ganz richtig
hart auf hart kommen die presse ist
richtig schreibt und wenn überall bilder
noch nicht alle dicke klar logisch aber
in dem fall eben auch und ich finde
ehrlich gesagt da kommt noch was dazu
die menschen haben so lange in der
kommune zahlt wirklich zu hause den rest
zum teil einfach eingesperrt ja die
haben wirklich auch wenig kohle moment
und was passiert denn wenn man da am
flughafen steht unseren ticket nicht
zurückhält und wenn man familien urlaub
gebucht hat ich finde das trifft ja
nicht nur uns wo wir uns einfach nur
ärgern was nervt sondern es trifft finde
ich auch wirklich dem fall schon die die
verdammten lang verdienten urlaub
einfach mal antreten möchten mit ihrer
familie vielleicht die ganze woche lang
vielleicht auch richtig darauf gespart
und dann hinterher was es für chaos sie
werden ja nicht nur nicht mitfliegen sie
müssen sich dann um die ganze
rückabwicklung auch noch da muss man
nicht entschuldung auch wirklich nennen
und ich sage es ist eindeutig das
innenministerium die fluggastkontrolle
das ist in der regie der bundespolizei
an weil er die politik jemals die
schuldigen genannt oder ist oder zu
setzen sind wir bei den bei den
flughafen geschäfts die haben auch die
köpfe sind jetzt sagen denn ohne hier
berlin schuld und so ich kann es nicht
mehr hören
es geht ja unterstufen verantwortung
berlin ist schuld berlin sagt es liegt
in europa genau europa wird ihr
unterliegt an corona dann ist das ein
gau
aber das ist das prinzip dieser
verwaltung und was sie jetzt mit den
leuten erleben die nicht arbeiten können
oder die einfach nicht da sind dann
werden sie den zehn jahren mit dem auto
erleben wenn in zehn jahren die ersten
autowerke zu machen wenn es eine riesige
arbeitslosigkeit deswegen gibt sie
können die leute ja alle zu verändern
aber das ist eine ganz spannende frage
die habe ich auch an sie dann würden
sich auch fragen wie konnte entkommen
nein das werde ich mich da
wahrscheinlich fragen aber ich habe noch
eine frage an frau treuenfels prowein
und zwar wir haben ja also die ampel
regierung die möchte ja auch die
sanktionen bei hartz 4 aussetzen ich
muss jetzt schon sagen wenn ich jetzt
sehe wir haben viele arbeitsplätze und
wir haben niemanden der es macht ist das
denn aktuell das richtige signal oder
muss man nicht mehr sagen jetzt muss
erst recht noch mehr geleistet werden
sanktionen müssten auf jeden fall bei
hartz4 bleiben und sonst ab an den
flughafen naja also ab am flughafen dass
wir da will ich jetzt nicht mehr ich
finde das auch schwierig das ausnützen
weil ich finde diese diese mentalität
und einfach alle zu schonen und zu sagen
dann meldet euch gar nicht mehr ist auch
gar nicht mehr dafür tun ich finde es
manchmal seinen eigenen kindern die man
muss auch ein bisschen abfordern tja wie
ich so wie sie aber jetzt sozusagen
sozusagen abmarsch ist hatte ich jetzt
wirklich am flughafen da will ich jetzt
nicht mitgehen weil ich habe also müssen
die leute schon noch selber entscheiden
aber immerhin dafür dass die hartz iv
sanktionen bleiben ja einfach nicht
dafür wenn wir wir haben erstmal den
verbrenner geredet jetzt sprechen wir
über die als vierte macht die fdp ein
wenig zuviel kompromisse und musste zu
viele kompromisse machen naja man kann
diese frage auch umdrehen und sagen was
wäre wenn wir jetzt nicht dabei werden
und ich glaube ganz ehrlich aber das
sage ich jetzt nicht um mich irgendwie
raus zu reden dann wäre die bilanz noch
schlechter natürlich müssen wir
kompromisse machen das geht gar nicht
anders ich meine wir haben jetzt nicht
mit 30 prozent oder so gehabt hätten
könnten wir dann in den gesang bestimmen
aber so ist es nun mal nicht ich finde
schon man muss kompromisse machen es
gibt bestimmt auch sachen das war keine
liebesheirat das ist einfach so die cdu
war nicht in der lage irgendwie mit uns
verhandeln zu können sonst wäre das
möglicherweise auch noch anders
ausgegangen und jetzt muss man halt
sehen dass man die flocke anschlägt und
dann muss man sich die punkte heraus
suchen bei dem man das hinkriegt und ich
glaube schon
dass das für uns eine position ist die
wir vertreten müssen und die für
vereinigen auch in die ampeln vertreten
müssen aber auch ruhig und das tun die
grünen ja auch dauernd sagen übrigens
wir sehen das bisschen anders ich hatte
jetzt gerade gestern eine sitzung in der
bürgerschaft das war ganz interessant da
ist es von den grünen immer ja wir haben
dass es gegen uns beschlossen worden in
der ampel soll ich mehr setzt sich doch
durch und so ist es ein bisschen also
die ampel wird die regierungszeit
schaffen gemeinsam das nämlich mal auch
schon an dass sie das schaffen werden
also das wäre ja wohl mal das ziel dass
man sich da zusammenrauft und den
bürgern jetzt nicht sagte wir haben das
jetzt schaffen wenn ich das dafür sind
auch die herausforderung zu groß und
auch deswegen muss man jetzt auch ein
bisschen kompromisse schlagen sind das
nicht leicht zu sagen uns was noch
schlimmer ist nun gefährlich sein
argument wissen ja leute in die sed
gegangen was system von ihnen
aufzumischen hat auch nicht geklappt hat
schlimmer schlimme ist ja ist es ja
moment wir wollen ja immer noch mal
sagen dass wir in einem demokratischen
land leben wo einiges auch ganz gut nach
vorne geht ja man hier manche auf hohem
niveau
er hatte wohnungsmangel geht nach vorne
habe jemand noch was an
wenn sie sinn wenn sie in andere länder
reisen und sich dann vergleichen da muss
man schon sagen es ist hier jetzt nicht
ganz so schlecht in deutschland zu leben
das hat mich sehr gut und deswegen sage
ich es ist nicht alles schlimm und ich
finde schon dass wir dafür da sein
liberale standpunkte da in die richtig
einzuschlagen also schlecker
anzuschlagen in die regierung das tun
wir auch aber man kann eben einfach
nicht alles was das ist normal dass ein
sehr gutes album in berlin andere länder
reisen ich war jetzt in kurzer abfolge
gegen tel aviv in reykjavik und in
warschau und da können sie sich wenn sie
aus berlin kommt eine scheibe von
abschneiden in gleicher weise in jeder
weise wie man den verkehr regelt wenn
man der stadt sauber hält niemand
kriminalität mich aufkommen lässt also
seien sie wende sich aber jetzt nicht
ganz mit einer vergleich lässt sich
nicht miteinander vergleichen und wissen
nichts zu sagen wir eine andere länder
fährt kommt zurück meint man im garten
eden zu leben
habe ich glaube ich mich nicht sagen
hören sagt ich habe gesagt nein ich
erlebe titel schicken wir leben hier
jetzt auch nicht so schlecht
nicht so wissen sie was mich immer das
ist was mich mehr verdächtig gemacht
wenn leute sachen dementieren nicht
behauptet wurde
niemand dass wir schlecht leben
vielleicht ein bisschen dabei unsere
verhältnisse er sich über unsere
verhältnisse wir haben heute habe ich
einen bericht gehört vom paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverband die armutsrate geht
übrigens auch nach vorne also hier in
dem land gibt es vieles nach vorne und
meistens in die falsche richtung erst
dann waren wir haben abgrund heute sind
wir schon einen schritt weiter wären
dann schon jetzt eine ganz kurze
unterbrechung um von dem garten eden
schon mal zu träumen und sind dann
gleich wieder zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 48 55 meinungen jeder von uns
hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt
freut oder schockiert
so nicht über chat buschi hätten seit
august aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu fügen
und sie sollen dem doch auch richtig
dürfte sein und das ist glaube ich nein
das konnte zum manko vielleicht einmal
kurz
doch das ist übliche anorak träger aus
ich hatte meinen beifall um eine sache
immer bekommt wer kümmert sich darum
niemand ist
dann ist er ganz knapp drüber sprechen
das ist ein fakt nicht fährt mich
richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
und nicht ernst nehmen also zurück und
machen direkt weiter mit cola um mit der
these von frau treuenfels prowein der
name ist willig überstimmt auszusprechen
muss ich sagen ich habe das leben habe
ich mit dem logo
na ja also meine tiere ist und das ist
auch meine sorge dass wir hier ins
nächste gronau starten und wenn man
bedenkt was wir hinter uns haben dass
unser land hinter uns halt
ausgangssperren schulschließung
furchtbare ausgrenzung von ungeimpften
mit zwei gibt das war schon hart aber
das waren grundrechts einschränkungen
das hätte man sich gar nicht vorstellen
können und das ganze was zum beispiel in
hamburg war auch wirklich wirklich und
validierten zahlen die zahlen waren
wirklich zeit dass sich der
bürgermeister aber immer ein bisschen
rausgenommen zahlen von intelligenten
ein bisschen so darzustellen dass sie
genau unseren kram passten was die
hospitalisierung angehen was aber auch
die instanzen ungeimpfte angehen und so
kam es dann wie es kommen musste dass er
darauf dann sagen wirklich regieren
grundrechtseingriffe vorgenommen hat
mich hat das richtig schockiert wirklich
also als ich das haus gefunden habe hat
mich richtig schockiert weil ich dachte
das muss ich hier die bevölkerung
wirklich nicht gefallen lassen und es
hat auch viele bürger schockiert das kam
dann so viele mütter und väter von
kindern ging auf die straße und haben
genau dagegen demonstriert weil sie es
einfach nicht eingesehen haben es war
nicht einzusehen das ist denen dann
passiert denn wurde dann gesagt ihr seid
ja corona locken und die wurde mal eben
schön in die rechte ecke abgedriftet und
da bin ich besonders sauer geworden und
hat dieses thema überlassen wir bestimmt
nicht der afc ich trete hier ein für die
grundrechte und ganz ehrlich das war ein
sehr schwieriger sehr schwierige zeit
für alle bürger in hamburg für alle
bürger dieses landes ich hoffe dass das
die gesellschaft nicht weiter spaltet
sondern dass die politik auch mal
zugeben kann und sagen kann wir haben
der große fehler gemacht wird
entschuldigung ist mal bei euch und das
machen wir jetzt wirklich besser jetzt
ist die cdu nicht mehr an der regierung
also die können das nicht mehr machen
aber wir müssen da wirklich einiges
besser machen damit die deutsche
gesellschaft nicht weiter gespalten wird
denn das glaube ich dass ich kann er
noch mal gefallen ich sage ganz deutlich
ich stehe dafür dass das nicht noch mal
passiert frau treuenfels froh war ein
ganz tolles premier wenn man hier als
bürger sind wie ich fragt man sich
natürlich was haben sie dagegen gemacht
als politiker als es passiert ist und
das zweite sind sie eigentlich mit
demonstrieren gegangen also das erste
tag ich habe meine verhältnisse ich bin
ja nun in der hamburger bürgerschaft man
kann hier die welt nicht retten aber
habe ich glaube ich sehr viel getan ich
habe mich von tag eins an dagegen
gewehrt und bin auch in der bürgerschaft
nicht beliebt dadurch geworden also über
meinen parlamentskollegen weil es hieß
immer so etwas wie der solidarisch ist
der muss jetzt auch den maßnahmen
zustimmen nach dem motto wer das nicht
tut ist eigentlich auch ein bisschen auf
der rechten ecke und außerdem ist auch
ein bisschen corona leutner und so
weiter und so weiter dem habe ich stand
gehalten weil erstens habe ich nichts zu
verlieren zwar war ich fest davon
überzeugt dass das wirklich
grundverkehrt ist was da passiert ist
und gerade in hamburg haben wir extrem
rigide maßnahmen gehabt haben sie haben
jahr zum ausweis schlagzeilen gemacht ja
weil ich dann weil ich eben ich würde
der pressekonferenz dabei war wo peter
tschentscher wie zahlen verbreitet aber
ich dachte irgendwie ich bin wirklich
sehr gut im rechnen aber selbst ich
dachte das kann nicht wahr sein was hat
erzählt so viel ungeimpfte kann es auch
in hamburg nicht geben er hat er einfach
da in die ungeübte eingerechnet welche
die gar keinen status angegeben hatten
und dann hat er sich das noch ein
bisschen zurecht geredet weil der
hospitalisierung immer genau das gleiche
und dann habe ich das er zusammen mit
der welt auch so wirklich mal nach
draußen gebracht weil ich dachte ist
kein richtig was aber war dass sie
eigentlich wirklich allgemein gefährlich
weil die die geimpft waren haben sie
hier am anfang dann in sicherheit
gewogen ich kann es eh nicht kriegen das
sind nur die ungeimpften es war doch
eigentlich fast schon gefährlich der
gesundheit gegenüber ja also wenn man
das wenn man das von der seite von ihnen
auf jeden fall so kann man das auch noch
sehen also ich fand schon deswegen so
weil darauf sind wir an diesen zweig
maßnahmen auch er beruht und das fand
ich schon eine ziemliche ausgrenzung da
habe ich seit mutter angerufen und
gesagt also ich war also im winter ich
kann meinem kind jetzt nicht mehr das
ungeimpft kann ich nicht irgendwie
einkaufen gehen wir können keine wandert
sein kommen kann man sagen ist
pathetisch aber nie das war schon echte
sorgen und zu ihrer zweiten frage ja ich
bin auf demonstration gewesen ich bin
auf eltern initiativen demonstrationen
gewesen und das war dann dürfen wir
immer nur ganz wenige mit abstand halten
gestand nur sowie meterweise auseinander
und habe da natürlich auch für die
eingesetzt weil ich habe selber kinder
und ich möchte mir gar nicht vorstellen
müssen die sind und eltern auch nicht
mehr in der schule was diese eltern da
echt durchgemacht haben und die musste
man unterstützen man musste alle anderen
auch unterstützung musste auch die
gastwirte unterstützen überhaupt alle
aber das war's mir wirklich besonders
gereicht und da bin ich natürlich
eingegangen und habe auch da gesprochen
herr bruder können die grundrechte
wieder eingeschränkt werden jetzt mit
blick auf den herbst ich denke schon ich
hoffe das wird nicht passieren natürlich
musste leider vollkommen recht geben in
denen wollte sie gesagt haben auch das
war eine generalprobe was passiert wenn
die bürgerrechte ausgesetzt werden und
das ist mit zahlen geschwindelt worden
und es ist am anfang die impfung ist der
beste weg zur lösung der krise und die
impfung das wurde permanent unterstellt
verhindert auch ansteckungen und am ende
hatte sich das verdient verbessert dann
ist das evakuiert und das ist nur noch
die impfung sorgt für ein minden verlauf
also wie weit kann man den leuten noch
märchen erzählen und es ist kein kein
keiner überraschung dass die ganze
geschichte hinsicht kollabiert ist kein
mensch glaubt dass mehr sie können
einfach impfkampagnen ja auch vernünftig
wäre überhaupt nicht ansetzen oder
durchführen weil die leute vielleicht
nicht im detail wissen womit sie
betrogen worden aber sie wissen dass sie
ja betrogen wurden und was er gesagt
habe das gilt eigentlich für den ganzen
vorgang ich meine dem wissenschaft und
in die medizin und die politik gebraucht
eine zeit um sich auf diesem fall
einzustellen das ist mir schon klar das
war trend award ist ein versuch und ein
irrtum aber der ist bis zum schluss
durchgehalten worden und dann gab es
wirklich solcher solche freizeit hengste
wir herrn montgomery denn gesagt hat
schauen wir auch portugal wegen prima
die es schaffen wir haben schon eine
impfquote von 90 prozent sechs wochen
später ist klar ist karola in portugal
verbreitet wie kommen sie uns irgendwo
und herr montgomery warnt uns von diesen
verhältnissen also auch die top spieler
in dieser ganzen affäre waren entweder
darauf aus und lügen zu erzählen oder
sie waren so darf ihre eigenen lügen zu
glauben also die entwicklung schon die
im ich bin gegen die impfpflicht war von
anfang an habe ich auch ich eben gesagt
es seien sie da enttäuscht von der fdp
als erst die einrichtungs bezogen
nebenpflicht und dann war ja auch noch
im gespräch frau streckt zimmermann zum
beispiel wollte ja auch die allgemeine
impfpflicht na ja wir sind eine partei
dass eine behandlung kann so ist es
normal aber ich meine marken wie kubicki
und solche ich meine das ist ja klar
dass man ja wahrscheinlich auch hier das
ist mir so meinst also ich war total da
gehe ich dachte das können wir auf
keinen fall mitmachen und da bin ich
auch komplett dagegen aber ich bin nicht
links unten ich finde schon wann genau
man muss sowohl die eine als auch die
andere seite wer sich impfen das will
ich hab's auch gemacht ich hatte echt
schiss dieser variante doch die vielen
dank dass ich jeden tag im fernsehen da
diese intensivbetten sagte ich hätte
mich mit allem impfen lassen haben sie
heute schon bild gelesen noch nicht vor
nicht schlimm unsere schlagzeile die
titelzeile ist heute da waren reporter
von bild in der spezialklinik und da
geht es um impfnebenwirkungen und da
sind schon fälle die einen wirklich
spricht seine stücke machen wo eine
junge dame zum beispiel auch viel sport
getrieben hat nichts mehr konnte also es
ist wirklich so das ist ja wie sie das
objekt der krone von wir haben die
ganzen seite gemacht
um auch mal den ein gesicht zu geben die
wirklich nebenwirkungen hatten weil
viele fühlen sich im stich gelassen
das hat bild heute groß gemacht wo ich
auch sagen muss das finde ich sehr
wichtig und sehr wichtig weil es auch
diese impfnebenwirkungen gibt und
deswegen die insulaner mit bestritten
worden absoluter sie kann aber
auch jetzt will ich eigentlich immer
noch gesagt sobald man eine kritik sagt
ich finde die impfung aber richtig ich
finde die impfung wichtig und ich möchte
dass alle sich impfen lassen es werde
jetzt auch immer noch dazu gesagt
eigentlich wenn über die nebenwirkungen
gesprochen wird aber hier ist doch die
frage musst das damals darauf muss die
politik doch eigentlich reagieren karl
lauterbach hatte gesagt die impfung ist
nebenwirkungsfrei ja also karl
lauterbach für dich jetzt gleich mal
gerade nicht verteilt und geist wieder
das hat mich wirklich 210 was der da
sagt aber ich werde diese ausgrenzung
von menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen finde ich geht überhaupt
nicht darum der gesellschaft wer genau
geht einfach 0,0 dass man das erste das
hat ja auch so familien geradezu
gespeichert und dass das muss dass muss
man lassen und das zweite was hier
gerade ansprechend natürlich muss man
wenn sie in jedem wirkung wenn sie gibt
also wo sind wir denn hier das kann ja
nicht sein dass die politik sei also
davon war jetzt lieber nichts für
unterstützt unser impfkampagne das macht
politik unglaubwürdig deswegen sage ich
ja man kann doch auch mal hingehen und
der bevölkerung sagen hey wir haben es
hier gehört ich glaube das würde viel
besser rüberkommen mal so ganz normal
mit dem bürger reden und sagen wir haben
getan was wir konnten und wir sehen dass
uns das war nicht gut wir machen uns
wirklich anders als ich da immer
irgendwie so drumherum zu schlagen das
ist ja das problem eigentlich was die
meisten haben also das regt mich auch
total auf ich bin halt jetzt zermürbt
also ich habe ein grundrecht und so
könnte dies auf regen ja
versammlungsfreiheit und so ich hatte
einfach keine kraft nicht so den hals
ich möchte endlich wieder in mein
normales leben zurück und ich habe mich
jetzt irgendwie schon vier mal impfen
lassen und so ich würde mir noch mal
fünf machen
wie sie diese für diese weise ich werde
das nicht das vierte mal tun bevor nicht
alles aufgearbeitet ist und auch nicht
die nehme ich sage es ganz offen ehrlich
am tisch ich bin dreimal dämpft das
vierte mal lasse ich mich nicht impfen
ich sage das auch haben aber
alle alle anderen um mich herum hat er
das kann machte und heute
absolut jeder wie er will ja absolut
nicht was sie erwarten das ganze ist
doch ich war eine nationale kraftprobe
merkel dazu gesagt dass man sich impfen
lässt es ging um das wohlergehen des
einzelnen
es ging um den zusammenhalt der
gesellschaft das gegenteil ist
eingetroffen wie üblich bei solchen
versuchen den zusammenhalt mit gewalt
herzustellen aber es war nicht nur herr
lauterbach montgomery mein großes idol
fresken von der spd die saßen einem
interview im zdf und sagte wir haben mit
seinen laborversuch mit vier milliarden
objekten und es hat keine nebenwirkungen
gegeben bei 4 milliarden gibt es keine
nebenwirkungen die frau scheint sie
nicht so etwas zu sagen und der kollege
der sie interviewte das weiß die nicht
auf der stelle das studio das war die
stimmung vor einem jahr und dem einsatz
dazu ist die bevölkerung wird sich nicht
weiter bestimmen lassen und auch nicht
anrufen lassen damit ist glaube ich mal
auch in deutschland durch das ist erster
zweiter das vertrauen in den rechtsstaat
und das vertrauen in unser grundrecht
das brauchen wir gerade im moment sehr
bei dem wir unsere demokratien und
gerade auch von außen angegriffen wird
durch die ukraine kriegt dann müssen wir
doch hier in zumindest noch unsere
grundrechte wirklich stand wird
verteidigen und nicht bei der ersten
gelegenheit sagen auch noch immer so wie
es ist dann ja doch nicht das will sie
teilweise minute weiter lagen wenig
ihrer partei
mir das mal lebens gemacht hat nach dem
verbot er ist die fdp will mal sehen ob
es dabei bleibt bis zunächst weil sie
regen sich ja schon länger darüber auf
und haben heute auch eine spannende
these mitgebracht dass die politiker
eher die angepassten belohnen genau das
so sehe ich das ich hab das ausdrücklich
so gewählt weil ich finde wir müssen
also fast alle menschen wissen irgendwie
was kein einzelkämpfer ist weil er gab
es ein paar top profilierte fälle dass
in der veranstaltung mit lisa eckert in
hamburg abgesagt wurde weil da die
antifa drohte zu randalieren das als
bernd lucke aus dem eu-parlament
zurückkamen und da wieder seine vwl
vorlesung halten wollte dass die von der
hundertschaft beschützt werden mussten
weil die leute ihn als [ __ ]
niedergeschrieben haben ihn angegriffen
haben körperlich sogar mit
trillerpfeifen im hörsaal das weiß jeder
weil die medien darüber berichten ich
habe jetzt absichtlich so ein bisschen
möchte ich davon abstrahieren und sagen
es gibt ja die meisten menschen sind
nicht bei der antifa die meisten
menschen sind nicht bei irgendeiner
linksradikalen aktivisten gruppe aber
was leben eigentlich unsere politischen
eliten vor wie schätzen die eigentlich
die meinungsfreiheit und da haben wir so
unsägliche sachen wie das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz 2017 was zu einem
irren overclocking geführt hat also dass
sachliche kritik an an die scheuer
oder sachliche islamkritik alles vom
grundgesetz gedeckt das teilen eines
heinrich heine zitates in der korona
krise wo er irgendwie gesagt hat der
deutsche ist zum untertan geboren der
erfolgt jede autorität das wurde
hunderte male jetzt gelöscht in der
korona krise als hate speech gegen
deutsche also massenhaftes unsägliches
oper overclocking auch ein gesetz was
von putin sogar kopiert wurde in der
russischen staatsduma wir haben so
sachen wie auch dass die die
hochschulrektoren in hamburg sich gar
nicht distanziert haben von diesen
extremen störungen dieser lücke
vorlesungen oder wir haben eine frau
merkel die ein un migrations pakt
unterzeichnet hat wo steht die
unterzeichnenden parteien also die
nationalstaaten verpflichten sich auf
ein klima in den medien hinzuwirken wo
zuwanderung als bereicherung dargestellt
wird da frage ich mich als
liberaldemokratischer mensch wohl ewig
denn hier in china oder was was soll
denn das ja also ein paar leute haben es
nicht unterschrieben sebastian kurz der
böse
aus österreich zum beispiel nicht unter
anderem aus diesem grund und da frag ich
mich mir geht es gar nicht mehr ich habe
in meinem buch habe ich viel über die
antifa über also links aktivistische
identitäts politische gruppen aber mir
kommt immer mehr der gedanke so
eigentlich leben die januar in
extremform das aus was auch ein paar
stufen höher von leuten die jetzt nicht
ganz radikale aktivisten sind vorgelebt
wird also meinungsfreiheit ist
gefährlich das volk der große lümmel
auch heinrich heine das darf bloß nicht
die falschen meinungen hören es muss als
großflächiger ganz klassisch prangert
haben sie das gefühl dass sie nicht ihre
meinung sagen dürfen man kann sehr
vieles wir haben
gesagt wir können alles sagen sie könne
nicht das glaube ich sagen was sie
wollen das heißt die meinungsfreiheit
schütze ich mein bild ist die größte
medienmarke des landes und ich sage
ihnen sie können jetzt alles sagen also
hab ich auch die meinungsfreiheit geht
bei der konstanzer immer um eine
bestrafung die keine diskursiver
auseinandersetzung ist also wohl nicht
einer sagt oder hat es hat dann essay
geschrieben schrieben der redet
kompletten schluss jetzt widersprechen
sondern es geht darum der herzen das
muss ein auftrag verlieren der könnte
aus der organisation ausgeschlossen
werden ich habe zwei fällen gar nicht
extrem viel protokolliert gibt es viele
aus dem angloamerikanischen raum aber
eben auch viele hier das kann das ab
sodass sein wie ein paar gute sind jetzt
nicht leute mit denen ich mich jetzt
besonders identifiziere aber die haben
in schleswig-holstein vor dem rathaus in
der kreisstadt immer mikrofon aufgebaut
also wer deren tochter ist im unterricht
kollabiert im sommer mit den masken
tragen uns gesagt wir stellen jetzt ein
mikro auf da kann jeder mal zur politik
seine meinung sagen und die das sind so
theaterpädagoge war sie die sollten
preiskriegen für so ein theaterprojekt
zu nachhaltiger regionale ernährung und
das wurde monate lang aufgeschoben weil
da die linkspartei und noch ein paar
andere gesagt hat das sind ja vielleicht
querdenker weil sie da dieses mikrofon
also die vertreten auch sachen die ich
nicht teile zur ukraine und zu diesen
fällen ab canon in einer weise dass alle
sagen lasst es ist eine bestrafung und
das hat nichts keine inhaltliche oder
man kann ja sagen dieses ehepaar
vertritt zu corona völligen quatsch aber
sie wurden ja bestraft indem man ihn
einen preis in höhe von 10.000 euro für
ihre nachhaltigkeit projekt enthalten
wollte und das geht nicht das eben gar
keine
denn das gefühl sie können nicht mehr
alle schreiben oder wird man
sanktioniert wenn man eine andere
meinung hat man wirklich funktioniert je
nachdem wer sie unter sanktionen
verstehen sie können liebesentzug es ist
freundin von mir passiert in der eigenen
familie leben sie kriegen etwas seltsame
blicke mir macht das eigentlich nichts
aus im gegenteil ich finde es eigentlich
sehr lustig ich stehe morgens auf und
schon haben wieder fünf leute ein
magengeschwür ich bin es nicht
und das ist in der tat so dass ein schon
sind die einfachen leute mit denen ich
relativ viel umgang haben schon das
gefühl haben sie können nicht sagen was
sie denken weil es im betrieb am
arbeitsplatz im verein von den anderen
nicht gern gehört und wir sehen vermehrt
halte jemand auf landing strip wir
kriegen ja auch viel zuschauer passt es
freut mich mal sehr an dann habe ich den
bild artikeln gepostet gehabt mit dem
krank durch impfung und dann hat jemand
geschrieben auf linken er würde das
gerne leiten aber sein arbeitgeber über
probieren auch was man so auf social
media neigt da habe ich dann erst mal
gedacht zu den arbeitgeber würde ich gar
nicht arbeiten wollen aber man muss ja
auch ehrlich sagen manche sind lange im
betrieb wollen die sicherheit und
aufgeben da darf man auch nicht wissen
saarow ganz viele leute sind damit
beschäftigt ihr leben täglich zu
organisieren wir haben nicht die kraft
und die zeit für solche
auseinandersetzungen das ist mein hobby
die anderen müssen um 7 auf stehen die
kinder zur kita bringen und dann müssen
sie gucken dass sie bei aldi die
sonderangebote erwischen da sieht es
ganz anders aus wir haben aber auch noch
was anderes wir haben in deutschland
schon die meinung durchgesetzt dass
meinungsfreiheit ein klima gut ist aber
nur für richtige meinung so ja nicht
dass meinungsfreiheit gerade falsche
meinungen schützt und im übrigen gibt es
grenzen auch der meinungsfreiheit völlig
zurecht man kann jemand verleugnen
verläuft man kann niemand sagen du bist
ein kinderschänder du hast deine frau
umgebracht es gibt grenzen und die
grenzen sollen auch ein gehalt das
richtig so sehe ich habe das netzwerk
durchsetzung selbst war ein totalitäres
instrument das auch noch nicht mal
funktioniert hat das ist mal das
schaffen und es gibt auch
auflösungserscheinungen im rechtsstaat
überhaupt ich finde es absolut und
segelt das irgendwelche hysterischen
kinder am pflaster festkleben
tausende von leuten strecken ihren autos
fest bei der hitze produzieren
unglaublich viel stickstoff und dann
kommen die bezirksbürgermeisterin
solidarisiert sich mit diesem kind ich
bitte sie welche einfache bürger davor
respekt vor der staatlichen autorität
als wäre hingegen die cancelled genau
ich finde das problem müsste man
eigentlich nicht nur da ansiedeln das
sozusagen die einfachen leute gehen zu
aldi und können ihre meinung ich sagen
ich finde das ist schon auch in der
politik oft der fall ich habe sie noch
mal selber erzählt ich bin nun irgendwie
relativ selbstbewusst erzogen worden ich
kann mich da auch bestens durchsetzen
aber ich sehe viele menschen die erst
mal 100 filter durchlaufen bevor sie
überhaupt irgendwas sagen weil immer
alles so fremd ist das muss man ihnen
sagen das muss man gender das immer so
machen das wäre mal eine frauenfeindlich
wenn man was ich gegen subventionen ist
ist man ebenfalls sozial partie und der
nunmehr und wenn das immer alles geist
und sachs und etikett kriegt dann trauen
sich die meisten leute oder sie sind
auch einfach zu müde und sagen okay dann
eben halt nicht und was dann auf der
strecke bleibt finde ich da haben sie ja
völlig recht ist immer an so eine
streitkultur dass wir und unsere jedoch
auch gerade hier so richtig schön sein
will sich aber anders muss noch sein
sowas da muss ich doch nicht recht was
sie morgen vermissten wirklich wenn sie
mal wenn man schon erreicht habe aber
ich meine dass sie alles für mich ganz
ernst das muss doch in unserem land
möglich sein dass die leute sich mal
wieder einfach richtig fetzen und dann
hinterher hätte mir leid oder es war
nicht so gemeint oder war halt doch so
gemacht also aber nicht die ganze zeit
um dieses langweilige
gelangweilt
können für den nach acht nicht besser
beenden als mit diesem plädoyer sie zu
hause können das ja auch mal
ausprobieren mehr streiten merkel
berliner politik manchmal ist es mühsam
und oft mache es freude und wenn sie
mögen entscheiden sie doch morgen abend
wieder ein wir freuen uns auf die chips
und vielen dank an meine gäste
[Musik]